derrick miller  read up on you impressive stuff  just doing my duty spoken like a true  soldier  i'm sure you recognize your old friend  the partner how could i forget  put a bullet in my back she's been  raising hair all over the globe for the  past two years  last week partner stole a piece of  technology  this is how we change the world  and i need you and your team on this one  we do it my way no questions asked  i'm in all right we got your back  [Music]  not loving the spot boss a pardon  he's coming here if you want to survive  we're gonna have to work together  derek miller just remember  we have all the manpower and all the  leverage  dad he's using my daughter  to get to me you got kids miller  just gonna get my little girl let's do  this  hoorah  come out come out wherever you are  you truly do not know when to quit  [Music]  i got your back soldier  you